[Musik]
noch sind sie ein bisschen wackelig auf
den beinen
die acht neun wochen alten rottweiler
welten des militär unter zentrums in
kaisersteinbruch und obwohl die
ausbildung zum wach und schutzhund den
welt noch bevorsteht ist heute schon ein
ganz großer tag für die donner die
waggons trager und tino texter und noch
einmal tragen ihre taufe steht heute auf
dem programm
und die wird kein geringerer als der
bundespräsident selbst vornehmen der die
leistungsfähigkeit des militär und der
zentrums sehr zu schätzen weiß das ist
schon beeindruckend ich glaube
österreich hat hier sicher etwas
vorzuweisen
nicht umsonst sind wir zumindest
europaweit bekannt für diese summe
ausbildungszentrum und nicht nur in
europa wir haben gerade zwei gäste von
der armee in ghana hier die hier
ausgebildet werden als als hundeführer
als wunder ausbildner also es spricht
sich herum dass hier geleistet werden
bevor die jungen rottweiler ihren dienst
als wach und schutzhund antreten können
erfolgt eine einjährige ausbildung und
die wiederum kann nur beginnen wenn der
welpe in besitz einer diensthunde marke
und somit offiziell ein militär- und
geworden ist
und das zu so einem festakt natürlich
auch die militärmusik dazu gehört wird
erst in der ausbildung vermittelt heute
ist mitsingen noch lacht
[Musik]